45 років служби в німецькій поліції,
участь у міжнародних і миротворчих місіях.
Німець Удо Моллер вже третій рік поспіль допомагає Україні
реформувати поліцію. Відповідно  мандату
консультативної місії ЄС,
це насамперед тренінги
Вимаєте подивитися і між машинами,
попитати в людей…а також запровадження
пілотних проектів. Найбільш вдалим Удо вважає проект у місті
Самборі на Львівщині.
2015го року там повністю переформатували невеликий
відділок поліції. За словами Удо,
це було непросто, адже в маленьких містах рівень довіри до поліції
був мізерним.
Ми пішли в поліцейський відділок,
і самі подивилися, що з відділком не так. І побачили,
що більшість поліцейських сидять  по кабінетах, і зовсім не
працюють на вулиці. Тоді ми сказали,
що треба вивести патрульних на вулиці, аби люди знову почали
покладатися на номер102. І це так і сталося.
За деякий час реформа дала результат. Поліція має нині
значно більший рівень довіри,
ніж приміром інші відомства.
Кілька бригад швидкого реагування,
кожна має спеціально оснащений автомобіль.
За ними закріплюються райони патрулювання,
видаються сучасні засоби зв’язку з диспетчером.
Поліцейські прибувають на виклик за 5-15хвилин.
Самбірська модель, за рішенням МВС,
рік тому стала основою для реформування
інших відділків поліції в маленьких містах,
сільських місцевостях. Уже рік за такою схемою
працюють і у Вишгороді на Київщині.
Майже вдвічі збільшилася кількість повідомлень громадян
з моменту введення патрульної поліції.
Ми отримали більшу
кількість повідомлень, які пов’язані з адміністративним
адміністративним та попереджувального характеру
Нині у консультативній місії чекають результатів
іншого пілотного проекту. У Борисполі
відпрацьовують модель, як поєднати функції оперативника
і слідчого. У майбутньому це може стати моделлю
для детективів поліції.
Перевага нашої місії полягає в тому, що на підставі
цих експериментів ми дамо поштовх для
відповідних змін до законів.
Удо Моллер задоволений
тим, як змінюєтьсяукраїнська поліція.
Адже в 2014 році,
коли він починав свою діяльність,
до європейців не дуже дослухалися.
Нині Удо Моллер має відчуття, що його досвід  і зусилля
Україні потрібні. В Консультативній місії ЄС працюють
загалом 120 європейців.Минулого року
вони реалізували в Україні 56проектів
на суму в мільйон євро. На поточний -
запланували вдвічі більше.